going series a more perfect union we
bring you stories that show how what
unites us as Americans is far greater
than what divides us this morning
Adriana Diaz introduces us to a young
Indianapolis man whose surprising
decision led to an unlikely friendship
good an unexpected bond is building an
Avon Indiana between 23 year-old Vermeil
Pat amber who's rebuilding his life
after prison and Brian Nugent the deputy
police chief here it was a lot I'm
trying to learn and unlearn
I need a mentor he can get me to I want
to be who can teach me what I need to
know and he answered all that was the
fact that he was a police officer a
quest yes my goal was to not go back to
prison but I didn't 100% know what to do
to not go back to prison I knew that he
knew that like he's the expert in what
did you have to go back to prison
six and a half years ago Remiel was a 17
year old honor student struggling with
the death of his father
I was lost that had a lot to prove I
felt like to prove it I had to be tough
I was a follower and one poor decision
led to the next he robbed a little
caesars at gunpoint with the help of a
friend who worked there
Remiel was arrested and later convicted
a felony armed robbery and criminal
confinement he was sentenced to 11 years
in prison I didn't believe it I just
started crying immediately why didn't
you believe us
because my son robbing someone that just
wasn't his character officer Nugent
knows this story well because he was the
officer who arrested remiel you know
very few cases that you work do you
forget and remiel was just very
memorable
during reveals time in prison his mother
Daphne Harris insisted on staying in
touch with officer Nugent I needed him
to know that he wasn't just another kid
in trouble so I'm gonna get Oh kid that
you would think you know I needed him to
know that he has a home he has a family
he has a support system this is who my
son is and you didn't want him to think
your son was a stereotype
exactly
after he was released early for good
behavior
Remiel wanted to get into home
improvement and real estate but felt he
needed a mentor to help then one day
while working at Goodwill a familiar
face dropped off a donation so I just
accent my hair you detective Brian hey
it's me how you doing
I mean you greeted him like a long-lost
friend what did you think when he asked
you to be a mentor so that's never
happen to me I said look you know I'm
happy to do it but there's gonna be some
rules you know we talked about we're
gonna touch base every month we're gonna
go out for lunch we're gonna have
conversation accountability it's such a
huge part of that who told you about
those coming back out of prison and
finding employment we talked about that
how does he encounter the questions that
he might get about his background when
do you volunteer some of that stuff when
do you hold back on some of that and
what did he teach you about that the
first thing that stuck in my mind was
that if I view myself as less than a
meal that I'm resting on you I can't be
mad at you to treat me how I treat
myself the m9 ex-convict I'm not just
black I'm not just Pakistani I'm
revealing what did you think about cops
growing up but were you taught never to
talk to him never to trust them they lie
and they arrest you that's what people
told me
but after interacting with Brian and
that's that's not the case I hope that
people can see with everything that's
going on is all it takes is respect on
both sides it's more good kids out there
didn't bad it's more good police out
there than bad
Remiel now has a steady job doing
heating and air I want something out of
life I want to be successful in order to
be truly free he's also renovating his
own home and going to school I think the
change that I see the most in him is his
confidence there's no better reward in
this job than helping somebody succeed
and achieve those goals in their lives
you don't blame him you weren't angry at
him never never
he treated me with compassion and
understanding that he never treated me
last and not once to this day he still
builds my Worth and self-esteem with him
in my corner I can do anything anything
with an unlikely mentor by him
side for CBS this morning Adriana Diaz
Avon Indiana compassion yeah yeah that's
what it takes
no kids needed attention doesn't matter
where it comes from it's absolutely true
what a great partnership that is